we're running semi yeah you're you're up
next this is a program we're running
over the summer it's the first full
program that we're running in a summer
it's shorter in length two and a half
months or so but a whole program it's
it's in this stream of theory plus
machine learning it's on the topic of
foundations and deep play so sunny
venture
okay thanks for giving me the
opportunity to talk briefly about this
summer program that will be much briefer
than the other ones and so yeah it's a
it's gonna be a program on foundations
of deep learning Mike organizers are
would have been much better than I like
presenting so Alexander Madrid from MIT
Elkin and Michele from MIT and Matthews
tell Karski so at this point I think
used it you're happy with it but you
don't understand it or at least I don't
so why does it work why doesn't it work
what's going on with these big black
boxes I think these are very important
questions because because it works
there's a lot of companies and a lot of
people who are actually using these
beasts and some of them making money
some of them taking decisions that could
have a high impact on society but often
they don't really know why it works or
whether it's going to work tomorrow or
in which case is gonna is going to fail
so having more theoretical understanding
of what is going on would be useful
there has been a lot of theory around
the machine learning for for like
decades but what what makes deep
learning more difficulties is I guess
this combination of having a lot of
nonlinearities that you apply one after
the other with a a stochastic algorithm
to train and and a huge amount of data
with each of which huge amount of
features so all of these put together
and the same problem makes it much
harder to analyze but despite that
harness I think we we do need to try to
improve our understanding to be safer on
what we do so I think that's the goal of
the
the program for next summer so there's
there's already a lot of things that
have been done but we want to bring
people together so that they try to come
up with even more rigorous approaches so
we've focused on four different lines of
research optimization which is you have
these big big models with millions or
more of parameters and how do you
actually fit these parameters to to the
data that you have and the last function
that you want to optimize since it's not
convex obviously it's even
initialization is becoming a problem and
how do you initialize and how do you
move and optimize is not clear and which
approaches will work and which will not
work without actually doing it and can
we prove how fast it's going to optimize
and all this the second even more
important is once you've trained this
big beast on on your data of course
you're gonna use it on some other data
hopefully from the same distribution
what can you expect so there's a lot of
generalization bound that exists most of
them are not very useful in terms of of
what they tell you like the expected
performance of your model the bounds are
going to be sold so lose that it's going
to be just better work happening now but
still more to be enough useful for
practitioners more importantly you're
going to use your data your model on
data that is actually not coming from
the same distribution because that's
real life there's going to be a lot of
noise there will be problems and and can
we say something about the data you're
going to see and and how robust you are
to small discrepancy of your data from
the actual distribution that you train
them all along
the forth focus is about the generative
models more and more we use these deep
models to generate data to generate the
very high dimensional data like faces
speech videos or text nowaday so these
are very difficult and high high
dimensional data can we say something
about how we do that
the second major focus is that because
these models are are very useful in
practice and people are making a lot of
money we really want to try to bridge
the gap between the theory and the
practice but also between NGC and
Academy so there's going to be a lot of
people from industry during this
workshop as well as so what are we going
to have just going to be 25 long term
visitors as well as 11 research flows
will have a boot camp for to bring
everyone up to speed about what we
already know and then two workshops and
I'm gonna go into more details in the
next slides one thing that will be
different from other programs I think is
that we're gonna have industry visitors
that will come one day a week and visit
the assignments for during the they'll
come from the barrier so you'll have
Google of course open AI Amazon Nvidia
IBM and Nike many others we organise
seminars symposia reading groups there
will be some interaction with the
concurrent programs like the the summer
cluster unfairness so we hope that's
going to be useful so the bootcamp will
be at the end of May and it's going to
we are going to try to go really as much
as possible to the state-of-the-art of
everything we know about the theory of
deep learning and then the next two ones
are going to go even deeper so in July
the frontier of deep learning will have
talks about really really cutting-edge
result in deep learning theory and
what's going on
so the imagine emerging challenges in
deep learning early August what's going
on the furnace reinforcement learning
this is it I hope some of you will be
they're going to be very interesting
I'm done question
questions look at participating subsets
of the program there would be a place
yeah so if you want to come along to the
bootcamp of workshops that's very easy
on the website you'd like to participate
in this once a week program of you know
visiting from from Silicon Valley you
know that it's like what about the
postdocs how much there's some suppose
doesn't program oh yeah yeah there are a
happy eleven a yeah is that what we call
research fellows okay visitor than sorry
what question do companies get to
interact with each other also and these
topics are is it per company no no no I
mean the goal is to bring everyone
together and talk we want to talk to
Amazon and Monday's are Google
[Laughter]
[Applause]